في عام 2018
وايضا في انتخابات 2022
حضرتك اكدت انه اولوياتك محاربه الفساد
واستعاده سياده القانون وضمان حريه
التعبير وقلت ان ماليزيا
تحولت لمجرد واجهه ديمقراطيه وليست
ديمقراطيه حقيقيه
البعض اعتبر انه هذا اعتراف
بفشل افكارك طوال الفتره التي حكمت بها هل
هذا صحيح او كيف تقرا هذا الاعتبار يا
مليجه
دوله ديمقراطيه فقط من حيث ان شعبها قادر
على تغيير الحكومات بواسطه الحكومات لكن
الديمقراطيه تتطلب ايضا حريه التعبير
وحريه الصحافه وايضا صياده القانون كل هذه
الامور تاتي جميعا مع الديمقراطيه غير
اننا ورغم اننا ننتخب حكومتنا فاننا من
ناحيه حريه التعبير مازلنا في الخلف لاننا
دوله متعدده الاعراق ومن المهم ان لا
تتقاتل هذه الاعراق
ما الذي يعنيه هذا بالتحديد هل يمكن ان
نقول عن ماليزيا دوله ديمقراطيه ام انها
ما زالت غير ديمقراطيه مئه بالمئه
نعم لكن ديمقراطيه تترجم باشكال مختلفه
عبر مختلف الدول في ماليزيا وبسبب ان
لدينا دوله متعدده الاعراق فان الاوكد
والاهم الا تكون لنا خلافات او اشتباكات
او صراع بين مختلف مكونات المجتمع ولذلك
فان كل ما من شانه ان يدفع الاعراق على
التقاطع غير مسموح به ولذلك فانه في الوقت
الذي لديك كامل الحريه فانه ينبغي ان تكون
لك الحريه في تحديد سرعه تلك الحقيقه كلما
استدعى الامر ولذلك فان ماليزيا هي
ديمقراطيه غير ليبراليه